viens
[ __ ] cette maison là, je ne savais pas qu'elle
allait être
là oh moi au dépourvu je
dirai quelques
maisons il y a une autre maison qui arrive
tout droit
ici allons un peu à droite,
je ne m'attendais pas à tout  ces maisons
ici pour être honnête avec
toi, loin d'
elles, je ne pense pas que nous aurons plus de
maisons
maintenant,
hé, cette maison apparaît
partout, je suis bien, peux-tu ralentir un
peu ouais, je veux juste m'éloigner de
cette maison
ok, un joli plan comme celui-là P Pine
et puis nous ferons un autre
plan, il y a une ombre sur la gauche là-bas oh ouais merde,
nous allons
faire, nous ne pouvons pas y faire grand-chose, nous le referons, eh bien,
qu'est-ce qu'on veut  fais peut-être comme tourner
un peu comme
ça, reste large, ok, ok, il y a eu
un peu de désordre,
faisons un grand cercle vers la gauche ouais,
nous allons le
refaire hors piste,
ici, je viens de
terminer, laisse tomber, finis comme  qu'il
y a une ombre en plein milieu de
la photo euh oh ouais, elle est toujours au
milieu ouais ouais euh ah ok ça veut dire que
nous, je veux dire, je peux le faire avec un objectif plus Telip
Poter que nous pouvons obtenir, je peux photographier au-dessus
ou en dessous de l'ombre
ok, j'y arrive plus haut ou plus bas euh
non non, c'est probablement bien quand nous ferons un
cercle la prochaine
fois,
viens ici, je ferai un zoom avant et
un recadrage jusqu'au barrage sur un
objectif légèrement plus long, hé, je veux  descends un
peu ce canal juste pour
ne pas avoir ce coup de pied hors de l'eau et
passer par-dessus ces arbres ouais c'est une
bonne idée
ouais
juste au soleil ici ok j'allais
essayer de le mettre tu vas chercher  un
peu à ma gauche ouais ouais je
tourne autour de moi, je me déplace vers la
gauche euh et je vais probablement zoomer un
peu pour
comprendre comment ça va mieux ouais d'accord donc je
vais à droite, nous allons nous aligner  nous
devons nous aligner, nous allons zoomer
à 30% quelque part là-bas et
juste nous soulever pour que nous puissions nous incliner
par-dessus la colline ici pour voir [ __ ],
oh, j'allais vous amener vers le haut
par-dessus ouais, d'accord, je
vais faire le tour vers la
droite, en aval, en aval,
je regarde le bon endroit
ici, à ta gauche, plus à
gauche,
tu l'as juste là, ouais, continue de ralentir
ici Ralentissez  ralentis oh tu
ne peux pas oh il n'y a plus d'eau l'eau est
fermée H il y a de l'eau mais de l'autre
côté peut-être que si nous étions un peu
plus loin du barrage et ne
le regardions pas si raide ouais nous devons
être plus loin  sinon on
comprend pas plus au sud du barrage ouais
F plus au sud oui je vais tourner vers le
sud
alors mais on fait un autre cercle autour à
gauche B mais on peut probablement se décaler
un peu la position ce sera plus haut
euh je pense que je  Je roule
encore là-bas, il y a un tas de maisons ici,
je pense que nous y sommes maintenant, cela ressemble au
bar local ouais et essayez dès que vous avez franchi
la crête, descendez un peu
plus bas, continuez lentement si nous
pouvons descendre le  pente ici
ouais ça s'assemble bien continue de
descendre
ici
donne à ton
Fe à quoi ça ressemble et c'est
bon ce dont je viens de
parler je veux passer par-dessus le barrage
maintenant continue d'aller par l'extrémité droite de la
[ __ ] ouais, continue d'aller vers le  c'est
vrai,
je pense que nous sommes trop zoomés, nous devons
être beaucoup plus intelligents, et bien, j'ai raison, je
vois nos ombres à droite
de nous, oh, est-ce que ça va,
ouais, pourrions-nous faire ça, pourrions-nous refaire cette
piste  et je vais le faire, je veux un objectif plus grand
angle, attends, finis juste la
photo, c'est
fini, la photo est terminée, je ne sais pas
non d'
accord oh oui d'accord, arrête d'accord, ok, c'est
mieux, elle
est à gauche, oh [ __ ], j'aurais dû
être là-bas, nous pouvons.  Je ne continue pas à passer
juste devant les maisons de ces gens ouais,
continue comme ça euh P ouais j'ai
bien compris, on perd un peu de lumière au
bas du barrage maintenant oh il y a
encore une ombre au milieu ouais euh
lumière,
garde-la comme
ça et  peut-être juste tourner à
gauche et survoler le barrage survoler
le milieu du barrage au-dessus du milieu
ouais au-dessus du
milieu et
survoler ces arbres à 10h00, ce qui a mis
le soleil sur eux, voler bas au-dessus de
ceux qu'ils  nous sommes au milieu du cadre
maintenant
ouais un peu de couleur sur le
ouais garde ça comme
ça ouais on ne peut pas passer devant les
maisons de ces gens là-bas comme ça à
droite voler juste au-dessus du point culminant
juste à droite de ces deux petits
Tres regarde tout
seul,
son ombre va être à
droite, notre ombre va être à
droite et ensuite nous ferons juste une
photo normale comme une prise de vue grand angle pour le
sud jusqu'au pont et nous juste
et  on suit juste la rivière, on se
place juste à droite de ces deux
petits qui se démarquent tout seuls en
allant passer à leur droite ouais,
continue de grimper pour
moi, continue de grimper si nous
pouvons, d'accord, euh Peter, pouvons-nous, euh, attendre  Je vais
appeler euh mon ami Pety et je
t'appellerai Peter ok sinon tu ne comprendras pas
euh py on est là ouais on va te
faire connaître le coup du sud oui
ok je fais ça comme  un plan normal ouais
tu viens du sud arrête d'enregistrer
ou grand angle ouais
ouais fais-les rouler de temps
en temps et puis tu suis juste
suis la rivière grand
angle jusqu'au barrage et descends un peu bien
probablement mets un peu plus euh 40 nœuds je
devrais  disons 50 nœuds, d'accord, nous sommes à 39
en ce moment, ralentissez un peu
plus vite lorsque nous arrivons aux
lignes électriques, aux lignes électriques et au
barrage, puis nous survolerons le barrage, mais tout
droit, tout droit,
pour avoir
terminé,
nous pouvons aimer voler  vraiment de l'autre côté de la
rivière merci
Peter B Je ne peux pas le voir
parfois si sombre juste les arbres et la
caméra ouais ouais moi ces petits
mods deviennent un peu plus sombres, la
photo est très sombre en fait, je veux dire, je reste juste
au-dessus de la rivière oh nous  je peux voir le
barrage mais c'est parfait,
oui, aucune idée de l'endroit où l'ombre va
être ici, euh, elle sera forcément quelque part
au milieu de l'image mais j'espère qu'elle sera
assez petite, je pense que nous allons avoir
une grande ombre cette
fois-ci, je n'en ai plus beaucoup
non  plein
d'eau, il suffit de
traverser le pont au
milieu du
barrage tout droit comme ça,
arrêter de suivre la rivière et aller
tout droit vers le centre, puis tu vas
tout droit
ouais et nous continuerons le plan
Peter dans quelle direction nous allons nous diriger
tout droit, restez tout droit
dans l'eau tout droit jusqu'à l'
eau jusqu'au pont jusqu'à ce euh pont pont
rouge ok donc on atteint ça pour devenir
la prochaine cible T ok alors on y
va oh
sympa oh Shadow je ne sais pas où Shadow
ça doit être sur la photo non ce n'est pas
bien je ne vois pas un joli reflet du
nuage image miroir du nuage ouais
c'est vraiment sympa et va juste directement
sur le pont euh Red
Bridge et garde ça dehors pour
garder ce euh blanc
prise de vue en angle, tout est long, tout est
fluide, la couleur est sympa
pour
peut-être zoomer un peu
plus P ok mais nous avons juste un peu
plus ouais 20 20% zoomé
comme commencer dans l'eau et découvrir que
tu sais ce que c'est sur l'eau ouais
P vers le bas
un peu donc on ne voit pas les feuilles ouais
comme R dans le ciel et puis euh essayer de
trouver quelque chose le quelque chose sur l'
eau pas grand chose en quelques secondes
genre en 5 secondes panoramique jusqu'à ce qu'on
découvre la rivière le
réservoir
et juste  allez tout droit
avec l'
Horizon et continuez pendant une minute comme
ça puis nous ferons un plan très très haut
dans une
minute pour voir tous les
différents lacs tous les différents
bars que vous pouvez arrêter
p je n'en ai pas assez  j'en ai assez
Peter, vas-y,
laisse-le glisser vers le bas d'
un plan ouais et vas-y les deux
ponts,
celui-ci est un pont blanc, je pense que c'est passer par-dessus le blanc, tu
peux passer par-dessus le blanc,
c'est génial, je ne pense même pas  les plus
éloignés au pont ferroviaire pour être
honnête,
d'accord,
comme un point d'eau là-bas, pas de
station de pompage de pum ou quelque chose comme ça, ils ont juste refait
la station de pompage ouais, d'accord, pouvons-
nous simplement passer par ce pont
au-dessus de la maison et Bridge
l'a eu et puis nous  Je ferai un plan très haut aussi
haut que possible avec les avions blancs. L'
aéroport, vous voyez tout cela alimente l'
aqueduc, vous voyez où va la tuyauterie,
oh nous pouvons filmer que c'est l'aqueduc
ouais, ok, nous ferons ça
après avoir fini ça.  mais juste commençons,
nous sommes entrés
dans les arbres, je suppose, et ce serait
un peu la fin du plan, d'accord, pendant
encore 20 secondes, oh, nous avons perdu la lumière,
on dirait qu'elle pourrait sortir,
mais d'accord, c'est mieux.  garde le bit B 10 secondes
comme ça et puis on va à euh l'
aqueduc et puis on fait un plan haut ok
puis on retourne en arrière tu veux dire la
tuyauterie le tuyau ouais pipeline ok tu
enregistres toujours ouais ouais suis le pipeline
ok il glisse slide  vers le bas a b s'il te plaît,
glisse vers le bas, pouvons-nous le refaire, d'
accord, un peu de soleil qui sort devrait être
agréable, je devrais rouler, je suis sûr que je
roule et je
reste un peu au-dessus de l'eau, juste
au-dessus du donjon P.  vers la
droite pour qu'ils puissent voir le pipeline courbe
ouais et ensuite vous suivez simplement le
pipeline comme
ce PO vers la gauche ici, n'est-ce pas,
pouvons-nous le revoir après cet endroit maintenant
ouais là, il est droit devant vous, je  Je veux
dire que là, ça se termine juste là, oh c'est
la fin, ouais, ok, où ça
va, tu veux voir ce que ça donne,
autant en avoir une photo, je
pense que ça redevient underground,
ouais, mais qu'est-ce que je suis  en disant, tu vois
où ça va et il y a comme une petite
station de pompage ici ouais ouais ouais j'ai
compris maintenant, allons continuer le
tir jusqu'à ce que la station de pompage ait un tir,
continue, continue, continue de
rouler, je ne sais pas où ça va
stop stop shot stop
shot c'est
vraiment on va prendre un shot de toute façon ouais c'est
beaucoup de brume ou peut-être que tu devrais
descendre un peu, on aura moins de Haze ou
ouais et bien on ne verra pas plus de
likes donc on est peu  un peu comme pour
le moment, alors faisons un tir comme celui-ci même
ouais, nous devons faire la variété des choses
de toute façon
ouais 8106 vict quatre de Far cross bien au-
dessus de 3 000 thir Approche de la piste Approche
300 CLE
Je te vois tout le chemin sur la
main droite  côté de votre écran là
qui fait toujours partie de ce réservoir ok
ouais
ouais ce que je pourrais faire c'est changer l'exposition
mais la
roue de construction ça
compte je veux changer la roue de construction
qui vous a permis de mettre P donner un b à
droite P
merci ouais ok nous en avons un peu  d'une jambe
ouais faisons une minute comme ça ok on
court
maintenant
06 Victor trafic 1h00 et 3 miles
Orting juste un peu à l'ouest de l'
hélicoptère localisé
2500 ok on l'a eu sur le T on
regarde 8 106 hélicoptère  deux
trafics enchevêtrés dans le Delta sont juste au nord-est
à 2 et 2 milles au sud-est sur le
localizer 2 300 en défendant
deux, j'ai eu le droit, d'accord, nous pourrions
descendre un
peu, nous ne pouvons pas vraiment, mais parce que vous voyez
là, ils font votre approche oh ouais,
d'accord, ils ont protégé l'air  l'espace, en quelque sorte,
ok, eh
bien, nous avons une
minute, nous avons une minute pour ça, ok, nous, ouais, nous
avons une minute, euh, si nous comprenons, vous pensez que nous
pouvons aller plus au nord, nous pouvons l'obtenir, oh,
nous avons besoin du barrage, nous  besoin du barrage
devant même si nous venons d'entrer dans le barrage à
partir de cette
position, vous savez et à New York, les deux
triangles Delta, nous avons
terminé, vous aimez commencer, nous pouvons le faire là où nous
sommes le triangle Delta approuvé, que
voulez-vous faire ?  je vais vérifier ou ce dont
vous avez besoin ouais nous allons vérifier nous
allons juste y entrer ce H
ici
alors bonjour New York pestar 45 est 2000 sur
un cap 350 et nous avons une usine de vol
5ar 45 apprach 33 nous volerons  ah cap
330 cinq étoiles
45 c'est une photo cool et peut-être comme aller
survoler le barrage maintenant ouais d'accord
tu
peux on ne peut pas j'y
vais lentement
corck continue de
descendre hé
ouais
tu vas tout droit et nous continuons à
filmer euh tout droit
pour un  plus une minute de plus et puis
nous avons
monté cette descente avait l'air vraiment
sympa tu es tout droit
ouais alors d'
accord nous pouvons
arrêter le réservoir et nous montons un peu nous
voulons
je
je me bas devant ce petit arbre ici c'est quoi
cette petite île ou cette bûche  je me dresse
quel que soit l'arbre qui me colle là-haut
quelques arbres ouais le vrai passé très bas
passe devant ce qu'ils sont, les
nuages ​​sont beaux dans l'eau ouais ouais
un peu comme ce qu'on a fait en K tu sais
ce qu'il y a dans le genre  Le
Québec au Québec ouais les reflets de ce que
tu vas au Québec oh quand nous sommes
allés au Québec tu sais en juin oh quand
nous y sommes allés tous les deux ouais nous y sommes tous les deux ouais
c'est ce que je
veux dire je n'y suis pas retourné depuis que c'est un
accord oh pas de
C all Way au nord de
C regarde le reflet du
pont là-bas c'est
incroyable vas-y va vers le pont
vers le
pont je dois le faire zoomer un peu mais
je ne sais pas trop avec un angle assez grand
pour le
moment  où suis-je en position de zoom
maintenant, je suis en grand angle
ici, la
réflexion est incroyable si
nous pouvions descendre aussi bas que possible en passant par les deux
ponts juste au milieu d'
eux,
cela ressemble au pont de Carney dans le
New Jersey que nous appelons  c'est le pont polonais
oh vraiment ouais parce qu'il est construit à l'
envers
je suis en Suisse je redescends directement
sur l'eau ouais
comme euh,
va juste dans l'eau
ouais
finis comme ça mais reste longtemps
comme
ça jusqu'à 55 ou
60 ans
Je
d'accord,
d'accord, il fait probablement un peu
sombre, ouais, nous pouvons rentrer à la maison